[Musique]
la cinquième édition de la journée des
assistantes maternelles s'est tenue au
palais de la source le public ainsi que
les professionnels de la petite enfance
se rencontrent et échangent sur ce
métier au coeur de l'accueil et de
l'éveil de nos jeunes marmaille accueil
des petits les aider dans leur
apprentissage leur faire découvrir des
activités leur faire découvrir leur
environnement les préparer à l'école
les préparer à bien grandir on est là
pour les aider à bien grandir fait en
sorte de développer tout leur côté
motricité autant au niveau de la marche
autant au niveau du langage
on travaille beaucoup tout ce qui est
manipulation pâte à sel pâte à modeler
on fait travailler aussi leur leur éveil
au niveau des chansons au niveau des
mimes et au niveau des histoires le
département de la réunion compte
actuellement plus de mille quatre cent
soixante assistant maternel agréé pour
4350 place un métier qui de plus en plus
se conjugue au masculin ils sont
aujourd'hui 17 hommes à exercer cette
profession
beaucoup recherchait donc j'ai eu
beaucoup de demandes lagonda senti mon
diplôme on m'a beaucoup contactés par
courrier travail en structure donc après
angers aussi des interviews en métropole
en ce moment pour parler de la mixité de
des hommes en structure donc après il
faut pas y a pas de jugement fait sur
les hommes on a tous souvent le fait
qu'on travaille dans la petite enfance
qu'on est diplômé qu'on est assistant
maternel aussi la perliculture les
parents y sont ils sont rassurés le plus
essentiel pour recevoir leur enfin dans
l'épanouissement et grandir en sécurité
depuis près de trois ans maintenant le
département accompagne le développement
d'un mode d'accueil innovants les
maisons d'assistants maternels il en
existe 32 sur notre c'est un
regroupement d'assistantes maternelles
pour mieux prendre en charge l'enfant
fois l'éveil de l'enfant pour
l'épanouissement de l'enfant aggravé à
une vie en collectivité mais aussi à
travers une gamme plus prolongée dans la
journée cette journée des assistants
maternels est également marquée par une
conférence et des débats au sein de
l'hémicycle les échanges porteront sur
le thème des comptines et du
développement de l'enfant
[Musique]